i'm joined now by the former
conservative party leader and the
architect of universal credit ian duncan
smith perhaps even more relevant um
ian douglas smith is a former heavy
goods truck driver um in duncan smith
they need 90 000. um
i think you could be back on the road uh
this week and actually you could be
earning even more than you do as a
member of parliament
yeah sadly i let the i didn't renew the
license about 15 years or so ago but i
am now looking into whether it was
feasible to either get my license back
or get a test yes certainly i um
i would be game to get back in the cab
as it were um but the one thing i do
know
[Music]
sorry the one point i was going to make
was one thing i do know about this
crisis
is that it isn't just sitting here
because we left the european union in
fact it's uh the the demand for drivers
and requirements drivers was growing as
far back as
2013 2014
and i had uh when i was secretary state
working with big rounds with the
hauliers
i gathered them in with the transport
secretary and said why didn't they train
british drivers and they said oh they
just don't want to do it so we bought a
hundred courses
got the price down filled all of them
with people who were unemployed and
ended up getting them all to pass and i
went back to them and said why didn't
you do that
and they just shrugged their shoulders
said oh no it's all too difficult and in
fact the reason is because they didn't
want to have to commit financially to
train drivers they just got them in from
eastern europe but that market was
already freezing up and even now in
europe there's 400 000
a shortage of drivers because of kovid
and no testing which we same applies
here so always have got to get on with
it and finance the training
well look i wasn't going to go there but
since you've raised brexit um let's talk
let's talk about turkeys
the turkey producers
cannot get the labor
to process and pack turkish we can't get
turkey pluckers and that is because of
brexit
are you embarrassed that in order to
have turkeys on the table at christmas
now because of brexit we've got to
import them from france and poland
no again this is all about planning i'm
afraid and covered too because planning
first of all because
there are these uh short labor schemes
that exist for people that do seasonal
work
and so there are there are plenty of
opportunities for people to come in
to do this sort of work as much as
picking if they require to do it
that's the first particular short-term
point the second point of course is
covid meant that
we had about three million uh people who
were european union citizens who
registered here uh to allow them to stay
and to work kovid hit many of them went
back home and many have discovered
actually they want to stay but their
other bit i have to tell you is i met a
very interesting man who produced
potatoes but it's very important this
because he cornered the market in the uk
on frozen potato products and all the
supermarkets and i asked him how he
managed to do that and he laughed he
said the uk is a cheap labor country
you've never invested in technology you
don't invest in people and it's going to
hurt you eventually well whether or not
you leave the european union you'll have
businesses that are not foresighted like
we are and therefore we beat them in the
market because we invested in technology
that's the story i'm afraid
of uk business at the moment not change
all right let's talk about universal
credit which was your creation
how did it feel to see it undermined by
the 20 pound cut this week
well actually it was undermined uh under
george osborne when he took about five
billion out of universal traded
originally when where we went it
meant it to be
some of that money's gone back in since
but it did require more investment and i
was pleased when these the chancellor
put
extra money in because it ensures that
people not just are supported well as
unemployed but i helped up the ladder
very quickly because of the taper it's
not an unemployment benefit it's an
employment and unemployment benefit and
it works when you invest in it because
dynamically the more people that move
off into work the lower the cost so i
would like
no no i want to keep the money i think
it's the right thing to keep this
investment in universal credit it's been
a huge success of all the things that
have gone wrong in uh the pandemic
universal credits the one thing that's
quietly got on and helps support people
without having to queue up at job
centres so it's worth investing in it
also gets people into work quicker so
that's worth investing in and finally
and the point i just made is importantly
that that money that cost will fall as
people go back into work so it's
important that we do this and even if
the government's dependent determined to
do this i would urge them to think about
this over the period of the winter not
do it now and think about it again in
february march as they approach the
budget when they know what the cost of
living is when they know what inflation
is and they know what the difficulties
are in the marketplace far better to
wait and see where we are as we know
things are
are moving in the wrong direction in
those terms and those will affect the
poorest in society the most so we need
to make sure we keep the support
measures in for them
so you're going to keep fighting through
on this through the winter
well you know the trouble is it's very
forget a vote i tried to amend a bill
the other day to get this
changed i suspect that bill will come
back from the lord's amended i just keep
saying to my colleagues you know we
invest in the poorest and ensure that
they have a root out of poverty through
work
and universal credit was designed to do
that and it's been doing it brilliantly
so
the old rule
you
you invest in success and withdrawal
from failure this is a success use this
don't invent our scheme
you are a london member of parliament
are the prime minister and the home
secretary right to stand by the
commissioner of the metropolitan police
i have resisted calls
for her resignation simply on the basis
in the past that i feel that these
things don't always change things in the
short term and when i saw the secretary
state uh give her the second term a much
much limited one by the way then i
assume that was because they were
looking for somebody to replace her
i do think that the handling of certain
events in london has not been brilliant
anything from some of the protests the
prolonged protests now
of the extinction rebellion crowd that
have cost huge amounts of money and
worse in many senses as an outer borough
mp stripped out the police forces from
the outer boroughs thus putting us in
some jeopardy uh during the course of
this but there's lots going on and i
think the um
the issues around uh um the the recent
murders the female murders and uh the
terrible problems that have existed from
that i think there are issues here
about leadership and focus and i think
the met has got to sort of have somebody
in charge now that understands the
dynamic of what they do how it works
best and that people can rely on them to
be both
forceful where necessary but also
helpful and can be trusted and i think
that's the bit that's got to be resolved
and it may require that she steps down
and that somebody else is able to take
over because i think it is time now for
a new broom as it were
you've been um sold you've worn the
uniform you've held responsibility
it's a heavy responsibility to be a
police officer but this man
went through the vetting procedures and
got his uniform and warrant card
do you think
that actually the procedures are
right for
revision and that there should be an
independent inquiry
into the vetting procedures to become a
police officer
well of course they'll have to look at
those vetting procedures but i must say
it doesn't take uh the smartest person
in the world to ask this simple question
when a man who is a police officer let
alone anybody else
is caught flashing
uh once and then again twice
what in hell's name is he doing holding
a police badge and being able to operate
on the streets he should have been
suspended if not sacked immediately
pending an inquiry on the first occasion
i don't understand how that man was on
the street and thus able to murder sarah
everard
you know we need to trust these people
and they have to be above
any kind of possibility of accusation
and the idea that a man can flash as a
police officer for goodness sake
and people think it's funny i think
that's that's the thing that's really
failed
you need to recognize that the police
police with consent and they are trusted
and therefore anybody who's his
colleague at the time who knew this was
going on
why in hell's name wasn't he immediately
reported suspended at least pending full
investigation had all his cards taken
often or sacked i mean i think that's
simple as that and you don't need to
suddenly have a brilliant person come in
and review your your your things that
you do to assess people what you have to
do is say that's it he's gone